[Musique]
bonsoir à tous et bienvenue dans ce set
8 sport sur tv à 60,18 l'émission ne pas
manquer si vous êtes un passionné de
sport local c'est parti pour le sommaire
de ce magazine golf l'open de france
sera de retour en 2022 au golf national
de saint quentin en yvelines la nouvelle
a été officialisée la semaine dernière
la dotation sera quant à elle doubler
pourrait attirer des joueurs de renom
plus d'informations à suivre basket un
tournoi pour les moins de 15 ans étaient
organisées tout au long du week-end dans
la commune de mantes la jolie de
nombreux clubs illinois ans participent
à ce rendez-vous reportage en ce 7 8
sports boxe coup de projecteur
aujourd'hui sur la team farrugia la
structure basée dans cours au palais des
sports a lancé de nombreux champions
français et mondiaux ce sera notre
module découverte d'actualité sportive
c'est maintenant sur tv 78
mais avant deux pas de développer ces
titres on va commencer par deux la voile
est une mauvaise nouvelle sur la transat
jacques vabre pour notre évinois louis
burton le skipper originaire de
rambouillet a déjà abandonné avec son
bureau vallée trois seulement 10 heures
après le départ du havre son bateau a
démâté dans la nuit de samedi à dimanche
on ne connaît pas encore la raison mais
rassurez vous ils ne sont pas blessés le
duo louis burton et davy beaudart
étaient pourtant bien partis les deux
navigateurs occupé à ce moment là la
seconde place du classement dans la
catégorie imoca une grosse déception
donc pour louis burton qui visait un top
5 à la fin de la course en martinique
louis burton va maintenant analyser les
problèmes techniques il se projettera
déjà sur une autre course qui l'attend
la route du rhum en novembre 2000 22
après une mauvaise nouvelle une bonne
nouvelle l'open de france de golf sera
bel et bien de retour en 2022 sur les
greens du golf national de
saint-quentin-en-yvelines le plus ancien
open d'europe continentale avaient été
annulés ces deux dernières années à
cause de l'épidémie de kobe de 19
le tournoi se disputera cette fois ci du
22 au 25 septembre aura une dotation de
3 millions d'euros le double de la
dernière édition organisée en 2019 ce
qui pourra attirer des joueurs de renom
on écoute pascal grizot le président de
la fédération française de golf il était
évidemment ravi
c'est un travail d'équipé comme vous
savez c'est très important pour la
fédération française de golf de faire
revenir l'open de france au calendrier
nous avons une super dates en septembre
sur le saut de sendai c'est aussi à la
malade que nous avons eu l'honneur
d'accueillir la ryder cup en 2018 then
it in l'open de france 2022 sort à la
104e édition du tournoi est la dix
neuvième consécutive à se jouer au golf
national de saint quentin en yvelines on
passe maintenant aux résultats sportifs
du week-end dans les mines aujourd'hui
c'est grégory à canal et qui nous
rejoint pour nous proposer un tour
d'horizon du sport ivy noir bonsoir
grégory vincent mickaël a effectivement
ce soir je remplace un bixente mais a
insisté ban forfait pour cette émission
alors commence tout de suite par de la
boxe oui et el benna nomma hamadouche ne
réussit pas l'exploit d'unifier les
ceinture mondiale ibf et wbo l'athlète
du boxing club d'elancourt saint quentin
en yvelines s'est incliné vendredi soir
à las vegas l'américaine michaela mayer
une défaite aux points après 10 rounds
assez spectaculaire le meilleur combat
de l'année en féminines selon plusieurs
spécialistes c'est elle c'est la
deuxième défaite en 24 combats
professionnels pour maiva hamadouche qui
compte 22 victoires dont 18 avant la
limite alors en tennis les bonnes
nouvelles s'enchaînent pour arthur reina
tenait le saint germanois réalise une
année exceptionnelle 60e place au
classement atp une sélection en équipe
de france de coupe davis et ce n'est pas
la défaite au masters de paris bercy qui
va venir entacher sa bonne humeur il a
été battu en trois sets 6-4 4-6 3-6 par
son compatriote hugo gaston en 32e de
finale lundi dernier un tournoi remporté
par le numéro un mondial novak djokovic
arthur rinderknecht qui pourrait bien
terminer l'année comme premier français
à l'arrêt c'est à dire sur les résultats
de la saison en cours voici le prérequis
se hisser jusqu'en finale du tournoi de
stockholm cette semaine le français joue
mardi son seizième de finale contre le
kazakh beaubelique du rugby et une
yvelinoise sur le devant de la scène
emilie boulard tenait son nom 22 ans a
fêté sa quatrième sélection en équipe de
france par une large victoire les bleus
ont dominé samedi à bâle l'afrique du
sud 40 6 à 3 dans le premier match de la
tournée d'automne samedi prochain les
françaises affrontent la nouvelle
zélande à pau et quels sont les
résultats de nos clubs divine wa ce week
end que nos deux fiers représentants
dans le rugby masculin ont gagné plaisir
tout d'abord qui s'est imposé dimanche à
la baule 26 à 20 dans la septième
journée de fédérale 2 est deuxième
succès d'affilée le troisième de la
saison pour le prc 8e de la poule 1 et
dimanche prochains les plaisirs oies se
déplace à tours qui va battre versailles
en fédérale 3 le rcv toujours invaincu
cette saison victoire ce dimanche à
l'excellent à l'extérieur 45 26 contre
rouen elle et versailles est leader de
la poule 1 après six journées
accueillent petit couronne dimanche
prochain mais il n'y a pas qu'au rugby
que versailles brille et oui en football
aussi toujours aucune défaite pour le
club de la cité royale dans le groupe à
de nationale 2 samedi les versaillais
ont gagné à vitré 2 buts à 1 pour le
compte de la 11e journée le fcv toujours
premiers à égalité de points avec la
réserve de lorient l'autre club
yvelinois poissy l'emportent également 1
0 à domicile face à la réserve du stade
malherbe de caen est les pisciacais 8e
met fin à une longue série négative sept
matches sans victoire prochaine journée
le 20 novembre parce que le 20 novembre
il ya entre temps le 7e tour de la coupe
de france ce dimanche 14 novembre vers
ça ira à lumbres dans le pas de calais
poissy jouera dans les côtes d'armor
contre saint julien est les deux club
yvelinois pourraient s'affronter au 8e
tour de la compétition en cas de
qualification enfin chatou sera engagé
dans un duel 100% franciliens réception
de nanterre handball féminin c'est
compliqué pour monty bretonneux une
troisième défaite d'affilée michael pour
les aînés montaigne qui ont perdu samedi
chez elle contre rennes 34 à 28 le score
final c'était la septième journée de
nationale 2 les yvelinois 7e de la poule
3 avons agrandi lé samedi prochain et du
basket pour terminer avec trois clubs du
département engagée en nationale 3
masculine on jouait ce samedi la 7e
journée et dans la poule f le
chesnay-versailles obtient son premier
succès de la saison 69 à 60 contre ormes
bon dernier le lcd 78 est désormais 10e
sur 12 enfin dans la poule g trappeur à
bayeux 84 à 77 marly-le-roi contre caen
en or basket 79 à 68 trappe et 4e
marly-le-roi lanterne rouge merci
beaucoup grégory pour toutes ces
précisions vous retrouve mercredi
prochain pour l'émission à 6 on parler
sport ou sur les chroniqueurs à mes
côtés sur ce plateau avec plaisir merci
beaucoup grégory l'actualité football
qui a été a marqué également ce week-end
par le départ du président du club du fc
versailles 78 daniel voisin a décidé de
démissionner après dix huit années à la
présidence du club malgré les très bons
résultats on l'a vu en nationale 2 le
dirigeant a expliqué être en désaccord
avec l'entraîneur du club youssef chibi
ainsi qu'avec les nouveaux investisseurs
arrivés au club au printemps dernier cd
accord l'ont amené à se retirer de la
vie du club le nom de son successeur n'a
pas encore été communiquée on va
maintenant parler à basket un tournoi
pour les moins de 15 ans était organisé
ce week-end à mantes-la-jolie
l'événement organisé par l'ès mantaise a
regroupé une vingtaine d' équipes de la
région coup de projecteur un reportage
de bixente mais rien senti steban la mie
câline basket go c'est le plus grand
tournoi de basket du quinze de france ce
week-end plus de 29 équipes se sont
retrouvées à mantes la jolie pour
s'affronter entre elles lors des
qualifications il le but c'est de faire
jouer les jeunes
la mie câline basket c'est un tournoi
national où tous les clubs peuvent
s'inscrire parmi les clubs les yvelinois
présent la hesse mantaise maurepas ou
encore maul qui l'a emporté lors du
derby contre épaule 22 à 3 on a bien
joué on a réussi à les battre mais très
bonne équipe en face
on a bien défendu et c'est bon ça qu'on
a gagné on sait tout jouer et puis c'est
un gars nous parents on peut faire un
autre match et ça je trouve ça vraiment
bien parce que ça à évaluer notre niveau
une compétition organisée par l'as
mantaise pour la quatrième année
consécutive le tournoi la mie câline
basket
on a le niveau département régional et
national
donc ça une finale après en vendée pour
toutes les catégories donc tous les
niveaux les trois niveaux garçons et
filles donc là on a deux équipes
aujourd'hui qu'ils vont se qualifier aux
garçons et en filles pour niveau
départemental et hier on a eu une équipe
qui s'est qualifiée en masculin
régionales côté garçons lui as
alfortville le levallois sporting club
se sont qualifiés pour les phases
finales qui auront lieu les 4 et 5 juin
prochains à saint jean de monts en
vendée chez les filles les sarthoises du
sable et baskets et le club hôte losc en
thèse participeront également au
prochain tour on va maintenant par les
cyclistes mercredi dernier au vélodrome
national de saint-quentin-en-yvelines la
fédération française a décidé de nommer
florian rousseau au poste de directeur
du programme olympique l'ancien pistard
dix fois champion du monde et triple
champion olympique aura pour objectif de
faire performer
cette équipe de france en 2024 au
reportage
florian rousseau est de retour la
fédération française de cyclisme huit
ans après avoir quitté son poste
d'entraîneur national le pistard vient
d'être nommé directeur du programme
olympique par la ffc il aura pour
objectif de partager son expérience
internationale et son vécu sur les jo
avec notamment trois titres olympiques
mon rôle c'est d'animer de coordonner en
tout cas est de fixer un cap pour
notamment par rapport aux objectifs de
réussite dont deux médailles aux jeux en
paris 2024 d'identifier les besoins pour
accompagner les entraîneurs les les
acteurs de la terre et des athlètes
florian rousseau aura deux ans et demi
pour remobiliser un groupe france
fragilisée après les jeux olympiques
2021 raté avec seulement deux médailles
de bronze en cyclisme toutes disciplines
confondues
la plus value est vraiment transformé
l'essai lors des jeux olympiques pour ça
évidemment il va construire son approche
il va la construire avec l'encadrement
il va mettre en place une équipe pour
gérer tous les aspects qui lui semble
important autour de la performance c'est
plein d'éléments qui viennent s'agréger
les uns aux autres et c'est tout ce
travail de construction qui doit
l'amener à faire en sorte que à paris
2024 bon soit dans une configuration où
on confirme finalement les résultats
qu'on a dans les grands championnats
internationaux
ce mercredi 3 novembre vélodrome
national de saint-quentin-en-yvelines la
fédération française espère débuter une
nouvelle ère avec peut-être à la clé
plusieurs titres olympiques en 2024 sur
le territoire évinois en bmx cyclisme
sur piste ou encore vtt
on va maintenant prendre la direction de
voisins-le-bretonneux pourparlers al
tennis de table un tournoi international
handisport est programmée cette semaine
mardi mercredi jeudi au gymnase des
pyramides le rendez vous organisé par le
club skipping réunira 27 pays venus de
tous les continents et des médailles et
paralympiques et c'est une grande
première pour le club on écoute le
directeur sportif de la structure on est
sur à peu près 180 joueurs faut savoir
que les plus gros tournois au monde
accueille entre 200 250 joueurs et que
la moyenne des tournois et sur 100 120
joueurs donc on est sur un gros tournoi
on est sur le premier tournoi donc on
espère pouvoir faire beaulieu après donc
pour un début oui on est très contents
de la dimension qui a pris stands si
vous voulez assister à ce tournoi
l'entrée libre il faudra se présenter
avec le pass sanitaires un autre rendez
vous à noter dans vos agendas la course
parcourir montigné programmé ce dimanche
14 novembre dans les rues de la commune
au programme un 10 km 1 5 km dans un
nouveau format qualificatif il y aura
également des courses pour les enfants
le départ sera donné depuis le parc des
sports ladoumègue à partir de 9h40 on
passe maintenant notre coup de
projecteur de la semaine aujourd'hui tv
78 est allé rendre visite à la team
farrugia il encourt une structure qui a
fabriqué de nombreux champions de france
d'europe et du monde le club a également
envoyé maiva hamadouche aux jo de tokyo
l'été dernier à eau regarder
[Musique]
aujourd'hui tv 70 de ses valises du côté
de la team farrugia à elancourt c'est
parti pour découvrir ce club mythique
[Musique]
tanguy farrugia est avec haute étant guy
farrugia expliquez-nous un petit peu
l'histoire de ce club le passé de ce
club alors le passé c'était moi j'étais
à montigny-le-bretonneux mon père à
levallois perret et on a décidé de faire
un club ensemble et on a cessé décidé à
elancourt est en cours td ouvert la
porte pour faire un vrai club où on peut
avec des structures où on peut
mieux entraîné les athlètes s'étaient
quand en 1998 je me trompe pas et
l'encours vous accueilli tout de suite
vous a offert ce lieu là où on est
actuellement alors c'était pas le maire
qui était actuellement il non il n'est
passé le mais l'ancien maire ne voulait
pas le nouveau maire actuellement à
accepter il a ouvert tout de suite la
section section boxe ça lui plaisait
et puis après on est les champions que
vous connaissez
c'était quoi l'objectif justement
s'était formée c'est ses champions ou
plutôt faire de la boxe loisir alors on
a toujours été très et compétition
maintenant c'est vrai que quand on a eu
des boxeurs comme marvin que ou d'autres
qu'on a la jeune marine petit sprint
petit voilà qu'on a eu à l'âge de 9 ans
on s'attend pas qu'ils deviennent
championnes d'europe champions voilà
j'ai des anneaux dans internationale
après quoi ça vient ça vient avec avec
la passion
le club est aujourd'hui connue partout
où on peut le dire enfants soir même
dans le monde on parle de vous dans le
monde est ce que ça vous surprend
toujours bonjour parce que l'autre jour
j'ai reçu un coup de téléphone aux états
des états unis qui connaissait mon nom
de famille et tout ça dans un boxeur qui
est des états unis et j'étais avec les
réseaux sociaux parce qu'aujourd'hui
tout passe par les réseaux sociaux et
j'aimerais je le suis toujours surpris
de
qu'on me connaisse à l'étranger où et
comment il explique
les résultats on a fait on a fait le
tour du monde on a été à cuba remettez
au mexique on a fait toute l'europe donc
je pense que lens à un moment ou à un
autre ça parle est ce qu'il ya une patte
team farrugia est toujours là toujours
été prêt boxe professionnelle
mais
n'a toujours pas atteint on est toujours
professionnel jusqu'au bout quoi la pâte
c'est aussi peut-être le travail on les
voit là derrière il court depuis une
dizaine de minutes ils vont encore
courir ils vont s'entraîner dur là ce
soir c'est ça aussi la patte
tim farrugia s'entraîner dur pour avoir
du résultat derrière façon d'un rien
sans rire s'il faut forcer un minimum
sinon on n'y arrive pas et c'est clair
que si je donne un exemple un point un
débutant on arrive à faire cinq pompes
et après le but à la fin de la semaine
il faut qu'on arrive à battre il faut
qu'on arrive toujours à se surpasser le
but le but d'un athlète quel que soit le
sport c'est toujours de monter une
marche de plus en plus haut et un
athlète ski et qui n'adhèrent pas ces
idées là c'est dehors ben je pense pas
qu'ils puissent faire une carrière
on est vraiment sur le haut niveau on
est vraiment nous on vise le haut niveau
maintenant tout le monde n'est pas fait
pour faire du haut niveau il ya aussi
des gens qui vont se réinsérer qu'ils
n'ont pas l'habitude de travailler à
l'école qui vont travailler à l'école
avec le temps qu'ils vont faire du plus
de le voilà qui vont du qui sont
feignants qui vont trouver un travail
qui va avec la boxe est bon à prendre
arriver à l'heure etc etc
voilà on est aussi dans le côté
réinsertion mais voilà mais non je
convie c'est surtout leur dû le but
c'est de prendre des boxeurs très jeune
et des menées au haut niveau ou prenez
également des boxeurs qui ont entendu
parler la team farrugia qui vous
rejoignent au fur et à mesure alors on a
déjà eu le cas voilà on a déjà eu le cas
avec maiva hamadouche
jean marc mormeck
c'est qu'a eu encore ai eu il y en a eu
d'autres ça peut arriver qu'on prenne
quelques armes et c'est
ça va être on va dire ça va être à
s'arrêtera parce que nous on est plus
club formateur que le club piqueur gens
nous dire oui quel boxeur sont passés
par ce club un des grands noms déjà vous
l'avais dit à maeva hamadouche qui a
participé aux derniers jo de tokyo jean
marc mormeck aussi qui a été acquis a
été champion du monde quels autres
boxeurs en participer à cette grande
aventure team farrugia il ya eu un alien
bâti christian sexus dusko ivanovic
qui s'était encore il ya eu valérie
kayumba qui a été champion d'europe afin
d'user à table
stéphane guisard enfin y en a eu un
paquet qui sauvent disons bienvenue un
paquet on voit aussi il ya des filles et
des garçons ici dans cette salle c'est
important pour ses importants oui sur la
mixité important est que ce qui se passe
actuellement oui ça ça prouve voilà tout
le monde peut s'adapter tout le monde en
a fait sourire quelle que soit la
religion quelles que soient ses origines
s'adapter et ça marche il ya également
un bail va hamadouche on en parlait
justement précédemment qui a participé à
ces jo de tokyo c'était l'été dernier
maiva hamadouche c'était une première
dans l'histoire du club la tête aux jo
alors oui j'ai failli avoir
dans les passes et kader arabe
[Musique]
ahmed el moussaoui qui a failli faire
les jo mais suit avec des désaccords des
entraîneurs ou même alexandra de hutten
qui est présidente du club actuellement
ensuite avec des désaccords de
l'entraîneur national n'ont pas pu faire
les comment les légions et ils ont fait
une par un parcours comme et comme ils
ont décidé de faire mais
ouais c'est vrai que c'est une petite
fierté quand même d'avoir fait les jo
[Musique]
les deux boxeurs prometteurs repéré par
tanguy farruggia sont à mes côtés wassim
ilyes alors wassim pourquoi tu as
rejoint la team farruggia aille là bas
de base j'aimais beaucoup les sports de
combat déjà 2 1
[Musique]
j'étais assez violent j'étais jeune
aussi
je prenais pas c
et à ceux des bonnes décisions et du
coup je me suis dit pourquoi pas me
lancer dans la boxe c'est tout je suis
commencé avec mon coach farruggia tanguy
il m'a dit m'a guidé il m'a pris comme
on va dire comme son fils tout ça il m'a
appris des choses et ensuite tu vas je
me suis dit pourquoi pas je veux
commencer à combattre et où tous eu dans
ses pensées des rats fils m'a beaucoup
aidé
je pourrais viser plein de trucs aller
beaucoup plus loin
je me suis dis pas
à pourquoi pas et
voilà j'ai commencé comme ça donc l'âme
à nantes est en passe de peut-être
devenir boxeur professionnel c'est bien
ça exactement j'ai fait un
j'ai fait tout ce combat sur une défaite
et puis voilà yes un peu le même même
programme pour toi alors toi tu es
arrivé cette année à la team farruggia
d'elancourt pourquoi alors c'est ça
alors je suis venu ici pour ma carrière
avant tout professionnel je suis
ingénieur donc je suis venu ici pour le
travail cherchez une salle dans le coin
dans le 78 et donc moi je vienne
toulouse a toulouse je boxais pour le
boxon c'est jean-marc ismaël qui m'a
formé juste avant pour ceux qui
connaîtront et
à qui se passe le bonjour et on m'a en
fait on m'a dit que la salle de tanguy
et est réputé c'était une très bonne
école
c'est là-bas où j'allais le mieux boxer
et donc donc je me suis dirigé vers vers
cette salle assez naturellement j'ai été
très bien accueilli à la fois par les
boxeurs comme moi sim et j'ai vu qu'il y
avait un très bon niveau ici et j'ai vu
que c'était ici en fait que j'allais que
j'allais progresser parce que je
ressentais mes lacunes en fait dès les
premiers dès les premiers jours ici donc
je savais que j'allais progresser et
voilà donc ces j'ai signé pour avec
tanguy qui en plus de ça une personne
une personne très gentille et voilà
est-ce que vous avez le sentiment tous
les deux que cette salle cette ambiance
vous aident à devenir plus fort au
quotidien
bah oui parce que moi j'ai commencé ici
déjà et on a une ambiance une ambiance
familiale et
on est tous soudés on essaie tous de ses
liens entre nous
on rigole tout le temps n'est labonté
lire tout ça mais quand il ya un travail
tout le monde dise mais dans tout le
monde isma travail et surtout quand
quelqu'un entre nous un des boxeurs il
en préparation il est obligé de bien
travailler et de se tourner on est là
derrière lui bah on lui soutient dans
tout ce qui fait
et voilà comme une famille quoi on est
tous soudés c'est ça qui fait la
différence des autres salles vtt dans
les autres c'est pas le cas mais si on
se considère tous comme une femme
comment elle est cette salle yes ouais
moi je partage exactement le même
sentiment c'est vraiment une salle très
familiale et je le ressens encore mieux
en tant que nouveau par rapport à voici
et encore une fois j'avais été très bien
accueilli ici et par rapport à la
société par rapport à ce qu'on voit un
dehors de la salle et ça fait souffler
en fait sont resserre ressent des choses
humaines en fait ici qu'on retrouve pas
et de moins en moins malheureusement
dans notre milieu du travail ou dans la
rue tout simplement est ici voilà quoi
y'a des gens qui ont des problèmes on on
en est là pour eux il n'y a pas un
sentiment de d'entraidé des valeurs des
valeurs de des valeurs d'hommes quoi des
valeurs de des valeurs humaines
quoiqu'il qui font plaisir en fait ça
fait souffler ça fait souffler et il ya
des grands noms qui sont passés par ici
a dit lahm ou m'a dit récemment marvin
petit voulait côtoyé aussi au quotidien
ici sur dans cette salle est ce que ça
vous motive justement à devenir plus
fort ouais bien sûr bat déjà 2
ad connaître des gens comme ça où des
banques ça avec eux de rigolade et que
tout le temps et
nous ça nous fait rire parce qu'on les a
pris un peu comme des comme des amis que
ça devient choix ça devient des gens de
notre famille et tous et pourtant ils
ont gagné des titres en france et en
europe ça exactement exactement et ça
change rien on est en ici on est tous
pareils on est vraiment une famille ça
veut pas dire que tu as ramené un titre
que il quand il fait la tête et où ils
sont vraiment gentils tout simple comme
tout le monde ici en mettre les gants
avec est avec est immédiat avec des
amateurs avec des débutants avec tout le
monde quoi laisser de rigoler de
travailler mais quand
quand quelqu'un d'autre part à son jeu
précises sur ta sueur ça aussi sont là
derrière lui le lâche pas il est dans la
force ils leur donnent des conseils ils
sont toujours là
la question qu'est ce qu'on peut vous
souhaiter à tous les deux dans les
prochains mois les prochaines années ici
à tim farruggia d'elancourt mois déjà
bas je suis de passer pro l'année
prochaine avec lundi et puis bah je fais
confiance à mon coach et moi j'espère
déjà une bonne santé c'est cette
principale et ensuite en effet pareil
1,2 de gagner le prochain combat ici je
les perds de progresser et de progresser
plus vite possible au maximum et voilà
et d'obtenir une rigueur en fait
quotidienne de travail pour devenir le
meilleur à mon poids que ce soit ce
point car amateurs ou pros
merci à tous les deux et on vous
souhaite d'aller le plus haut possible
[Musique]
boxeuse du club est désormais à mes
côtés mariam alors mariam pourquoi je
suis arrivé ici at-il farruggia des
locaux alors j'avais commencé au tout
départ par de la boxe thaï attrape et
moment c'est l'entraîneur qui était
élève ici maram un jour pour essayer et
j'ai bien aimé l'esprit vraiment
professionnel où c'est plus dur croire
mais du coup j'ai essayé j'ai bien oui
on louait les entraînements sur masson
assez dur ici est-ce que tu le ressens
toi ouais tout à nous ça fait longtemps
que je fais du sport
lorsqu'on intense et c'est vrai que
c'est la première fois où auchan
difficulté comment ressort à la fin d'un
entraînement de la team farrugia à bord
moi qui rendit alors on a juste envie
c'est de se doucher dorment
c'est très très dur très dur c'est comme
une fois par semaine à tous les jours
les jours du lundi au vendredi et du
coup toi ton objectif c'est d'être
boxeuse professionnelle c'est bien ça
c'est ça ouais pourquoi pas parce que je
m'entraîne dur et
et je veux qu'ils aient finalité
derrière et je vais voir ce que je joue
aussi en professionnel être boxeuse ici
on l'a vue tandis farruggia le coach et
il tient beaucoup il veut qu'ils aient
beaucoup de filles ici est-ce que tu l'a
ressenti toi aussi
malgré le niveau les niveaux différents
il nous fait tourner toutes ensemble
c'est vraiment d'intégrer les filles et
c'est vrai que dans les autres vous
jettez ya pas beaucoup de filles donc là
ça fait plaisir et on espère que ça va
se développer à l'avenir dans tous les
clubs de france ça motive encore plus ou
pas oui oui totalement et moi j'essaye
aussi de mettre en avoir un box jolie
sont des raisons du coup j'essaye de
motiver un maximum de filles se montre
au sport et surtout à boxer et ça marche
bien des plus grands objectifs un toit
badia de passer pro est d'avoir un
maximum de
[Musique]
latifa roja c'est donc un club mythique
avec des boxeurs a reconnu et des
boxeurs en devenir en les regardant
s'entraîner à moins ça m'a donné envie
de boxer à l'esj pour les gants
c'est la fin de cette émission merci
l'avoir suivi à bientôt sur tv 78
[Musique]